[Musik]
In God We Trust ist der
Status des Anführers mit gestohlenem Otter-
Kalkül enorm in und umgekehrt und
Vista hat die gesamte Definition kiboshed,
so dass Filter Nachman Attica Castries Agha
Helm sogar vorhersagt, dass der geplünderte Koch Aaron
Nadia Bolts Dampf im neuen si Lang
Standstar ist  Paulo markiert eine Neuheit und ist
tatsächlich eine Missbildung auf dem kg für diesen
guten Morgen für beide Fieber. Er wurde
zu einem guten Morgen-Roboter V von Chavez
Karate, sogar genau, sie ist in einer ERISA und
geht und ist ein Star-Superstar
Ballon-Fiestas brauchen Super-
Candice Fallon und
Zorba  Ich werde es tun, indem ich nach
innen schaue und versuche, vielleicht eine
schwierige Wahrheit über mich selbst herauszufinden und
die Dinge auf diese Weise zu veranschaulichen, anstatt
als Experte zu den Leuten herabzulassen
Ja, Kyle-Vertreterin Alicia
befeuchtet alle Medien, also Melodien, bei denen Sie es nicht spüren
, der Service VN-
Alleinstellungsmerkmal prickelnd, vielleicht erregt es anfangs die
Aufmerksamkeit der Leute, aber ich
habe vier Bücher und drei New York
Times-Bestseller geschrieben, und sie sind es  übersetzt
in acht sprachen, das passiert nicht,
nur weil man tätowiert ist, also denke ich
, dass es sicherlich die aufmerksamkeit der leute auf sich zieht,
aber ich glaube nicht,
dass es jemals ausreicht, um
die aufmerksamkeit von jemandem zu fesseln, mr.  Gaynor,
deshalb sind dies zwei Trennungen, die
du nicht hast, ja, ich bin ein toller Link
inés höchster Sünder und heiliges Kanji.
Surabaya clearin war ein super Spielzeug, das
nicht von der East High war
Cart oder so, es ist Latein, ja,
und es war diese Idee von Martin Luther,
dass wir alle
gleichzeitig Sünder und Heilige sind, wie
hundert Prozent von beidem, während einige
Theologien Menschen als diese
schrecklichen, verrückten Kreaturen sehen würden, die Sie wissen,
die einfach alle sind  schlecht, ja, oder es gibt eine
Art Philosophie und Theologie, die
sagt, oh nein, Menschen sind unser Gott ähnlich
und alles Gute ist in uns und
wir können in keinem dieser Dinge vollständig geheiligt werden,
die sich wie
genaue Beschreibungen tatsächlicher
Menschen anfühlen und so  Ich denke, wenn ich sage, dass
wir immer eine Kombination aus beidem sind,
fühlt es sich einfach genauer und
letztendlich auch hoffnungsvoller an
als eines der Extreme,
das uns als das wh verkauft wird  Die alte Wahrheit
war reif, aber lass uns sehen,
dass Dinah bald sehr verbraucht ist.
Ich glaube, ich habe gesehen, wie es sich
anfühlt, als hätte Gott es geschafft, so
schöne erlösende Dinge durch
mich zu tun, obwohl ich es mag  Ich bin
zynisch und das kann eine schreckliche
Einstellung haben und ich bin sehr wertend, wie
es diese Dinge gibt, in denen
ich ein Alkoholiker bin
aber ich kann
immer noch an den schönen
dingen der welt teilhaben, also ist das für mich wie
ein aspekt, dass meine versagen oder meine
fehler nie das letzte wort sind
Maria
Magdalena bekam ich, als ich im Seminar war,
als eine Möglichkeit, mich daran zu erinnern, dass
ich berufen wurde, ein Prediger zu sein,
trotz vielleicht nicht trotz irgendwelcher meiner
Fehler, aber vielleicht wegen meiner
Fehler und Maria Magdalena war die
erste Zeugin der Auferstehung und
sie  war t  Die erste Predigerin,
ich meine, ohne ihr Zeugnis gibt es kein
Christentum
und dass sie auserwählt wurde, und während die
Geschichte uns glauben lässt, dass sie eine
Prostituierte war, bestätigt der Text das nicht
und das
stimmt nicht wirklich, es ist eine Verschmelzung verschiedener
Charaktere, aber ähm, aber sie  Sie wurde von
Dämonen ausgetrieben, also hatte
sie Dinge, mit denen sie zu kämpfen hatte, von denen sie
schließlich geheilt wurde, als
Ergebnis ihrer Begegnung mit Christus, und
ich habe darauf Bezug genommen, also ja, sie ist eine
wichtige Figur für mich mm-hmm in
Interviews  für Venezia Initiative Schauspieler
Park mi vida Folge Berechnung zu sehen
so geschlagen ein Schleim Ito und Essig
Kurse sind Sherlock Martin Gedankenfresser
Antwort Isis Iltis bald müssen wir uns
erstmal wollen in nein ich meine das 100%
das ist meine Art von Glauben
Ich mag Glauben  wird
uns wirklich als diese Art der Reinigung oder
Heiligung verkauft, als ob wir mit
genügend Gebet oder sogar mit genügend Yoga
alle unsere Muskeln glätten könnten,
Yoga's oh  Ich mache viel, ja, ich
praktiziere es viel, es hat nicht
ganz bei mir funktioniert, wie mein großer Traum ist,
in einer Yogastunde nicht wütend zu werden, und eines Tages ist es
vielleicht nicht passiert,
aber uns wird so viel Spiritualität verkauft  eine Art,
uns an all den
Ecken und Kanten zu glätten, uns rein zu machen, als ob
wir uns mit genügend dieser Praktiken
heiligen können, aber ich denke,
dass die Ecken und Kanten
unserer Menschlichkeit genug
Struktur auf uns erzeugen, damit wir uns verbinden können  zu Gott
und zueinander, nicht durch
diese reinen Dinge, durch diese glatten
Dinge über uns, sondern durch die rauen
Dinge. Ich fühle mich nie mit jemandem verbunden,
bis sie mir schreckliche
Dinge über sich selbst erzählen
Nun, ja, ich muss nicht
irgendwie die
glänzendsten Teile von mir präsentieren, diese Dinge sind
in gewisser Weise ohne
spirituelle Hilfe in Ordnung, aber ich brauche so viel Hilfe mit den
rauen Teilen von mir und ich glaube
so sehr an Gnade  dass ich mich nie schäme,
zuzugeben, warum ich es brauche, diese Situation
hier bei Fischstäbchen ist unwohl,
es ist der junge Johan, den ich vertreibe, der in
Savarin eingeschlafen ist, noch stärkerer Zak, Alkoholiker,
Corinthian, suka, komm, lese die
siebzig, nicht nur so lange - bitte triff
Kate, ich werde sehen  Hier geht es beneidenswert um das Designproblem von
Paladin Cecilia Kristen.
Dies sind Kombinationen von sehr schleppenden Personen, die körperkritisch sind.
Meine Kritiker spielen
für mich fast keine Rolle, und der
Grund dafür ist, dass Menschen, die sich von
der Art des Christentums angezogen fühlen, das sich wirklich darauf
konzentriert, die Körper der Menschen zu
kontrollieren  Sexualität kontrolliert
ihren Glauben und steckt die Menschen in diese
sehr strenge Art von Metallbox, und das ist
das Christentum, sie haben so viele
Pastoren für sie, ja, es gibt so viele
Bücher für sie, es gibt so viele Redner
auf Konferenzen, die nur für sie sind, die
sie nicht brauchen  Ich mag, ich bin nicht für sie
und so bin ich zu den Menschen berufen, für
die diese Art von Christentum überhaupt nicht
zwingend ist, weil viele
Menschen fühlen sich von den schönen
Aspekten des christlichen Denkens
und Handelns angezogen, sie fühlen sich von der Gabe angezogen,
aber sie sind wirklich abgeschreckt von der
Verpackung, in der es sich befindet, und ich denke, so
viel vom Christentum hat die
Verpackung in der obigen Gabe verwirrt  Symptom
bei Schisma wird hier auch von Gong-Gong
gesprochen ELISA der stellvertretende Sous-Chef bei
Gewalt von Ich unterrichte Muslime im christlichen
Buchladen NICHD für Husten
nein nein christliche Buchläden würden sie nie
führen aber sie finden sie bei
Barnes & Noble wie normale Buchhandlungen
richtig  Soweit ich also sagen kann, sind die Menschen
, die sich zu diesen Büchern hingezogen fühlen, Menschen
, die von dieser Art
des beschämenden, legalistischen Christentums irgendwie unzufrieden sind, aber
immer noch von Jesus gedrängt werden, und
deshalb verbringe ich die meiste Zeit meines Lebens damit,
herumzureisen und auf Veranstaltungen zu sprechen und
Leute erzählen mir ihre Geschichten und sie
sagen mir, hey, ich bin in einer Kirche aufgewachsen und
jetzt gehöre ich nicht dazu,
ja, und normalerweise ist es, weil Sie wissen, dass
ihre Mutter sich von ihrem missbräuchlichen Vater scheiden ließ
und die Kirche ließ sie
nicht mehr zur Kommunion gehen oder sie sind schwul und
ihnen wurde gesagt, du musst dich
zwischen deiner Sexualität und deiner
Spiritualität oder solchen Dingen entscheiden
Weil ich einfach das Gefühl habe, dass Jesus
nicht viel zu bieten hatte mm-hmm, das ist nie
das Problem, also denke ich, dass es Leute gibt, die
Jesus manchmal insgeheim wirklich lieben, aber
Kirchen, die seinen Namen tragen, nicht ausstehen können,
und ich denke oft, dass das wer ist  Mein
Publikum ist mmm, ich bin Angus Yaga, eine
Art Akuna, der Phil Burgers Oktave nicht erfüllt,
als er herausfand, dass die inneren
Reinheitsringe als Kuhfelle überwacht werden, aber
ich gehe, Mann, ich bin Susan, um die
SONA-
feierliche Kunst zu unterstützen, meine Philosophie
Was hier passiert ist, der Kanal kommt auf den Vasquez-
Kanal, also war der Reinheitsring ein Teil davon.
Es gab die Reinheitsbewegung in Amerika
, die in meinen Momenten tiefen
Mitgefühls, die sehr selten sind, aber ja,
in meinen Momenten des Mitgefühls weiß
ich das  Grund, warum diese
Bewegung als Folge der AIDS-
Krise begann, und deshalb dachten christliche
Eltern, dass Sex Menschen tötet. Ja, wie
können wir unsere Kinder schützen, aber sie
haben das Ziel überschritten, weil
sie sagten, sieh, Gottes Wille ist
das  Sie lösen sich vollständig von Ihrer
eigenen sexuellen Natur und Ihren Wünschen, bis
Sie verheiratet sind, und so wurden besonders
Mädchen diese Reinheitsringe als
Versprechen gegeben, und es war ein wenig gruselig,
weil ihr Vater kommen
und ihnen Blumen bringen würde und sie gehen würden
Ein Tanz, als wäre es ein Date und es
gab 80 Bälle, ja, einen Reinheitsball, und
dann steckte ihr Vater ihnen diesen Ring an
den Finger, und das Mädchen mit 11 oder 12
Jahren ist nicht Kearneysville Home
Mesquita, bitte, bevor sie überhaupt wissen,
was Sex ist  oder was sie wollen oder sogar
wer
sie sind, versprechen sie ihrem Gott in ihrer
Kirche und ihrem Vater ja, dass
sie keinen Sex haben werden, bis ein gleichgültiger Mann ihr einen
weiteren Ring an den Finger steckt, wenn sie
mich fertig macht  si diese Eamonn
danfa top das stimmt das stimmt
also also gibst du deine
sexualität an einen mann bis du sie
an einen anderen gibst und sie gehört
dir nie und ich habe so viele junge frauen getroffen
die natürlich gegangen sind  zusammen mit dem, aber
später im Leben war es für sie irgendwie lähmend
, dass sie sich nicht mit
dem verbinden konnten, was ihre
eigenen Wünsche waren, wer sie als
sexuelles Wesen waren, und als würden sie versuchen,
ausgefranste Drähte und so weiter zu verbinden  war
für viele Frauen wirklich schädlich und so hatte ich
diesen Traum, dass ich wollte, dass Frauen Männer in
ihren Reinheitsringen haben und ich würde
sie in eine Skulptur einer Vagina schmelzen und
weil es diesen Vers in der Bibel gibt
, der davon spricht, unsere Schwerter hineinzuschlagen
Pflugscharen und unsere Speere in
Asthaken, ja, also ist es dieses biblische Konzept,
zu sagen, dass wir etwas nehmen,
das uns geschadet hat, und wir werden
es in etwas umwandeln, das uns heilt, und so habe
ich das gemacht und es war ein Stück, das
entworfen wurde  durch das Wo  Der Mann, der all
meinen Schmuck herstellt, ihr Name ist Nancy Anderson,
und sie hat eine Firma namens Sweet Bird
Studio, sie macht den größten Teil meines Schmucks, und
sie hatte den
Reinheitsring zu einer Vagina-Skulptur geschmolzen, und dann
gab ich ihn auf der Bühne bei a  Konferenz, die Konferenz der
Macher, ja, das ist eine
feministische Gruppe. Ich habe sie Gloria
Steinem Association gegeben. Ja, ja, Affinitätssuche,
Schaltfläche cc. ABBA-Gedanken. Ich
stimme zu, also Weichei, Bouchard,
RVD  Wir haben jetzt Internet-
Verfügbarkeit auf dem Anka-Portikus-Telefon von
diesen Verunreinigungsringen. Ja, es geht
immer noch weiter, und ich hoffe, dass die
Mädchen, die dazu verleitet wurden,
als sie so jung waren, ihren
Weg zu sich selbst und ihren eigenen Körpern finden
und  ihre eigene Sexualität schließlich
trotz der Tatsache, dass die Kirche
versucht hat, all diese Ruander
in der Schisma-Theorie nach seinem Axiom zu schließen,
und zwar die Frauen, die Frauen, die sie eingeschickt
haben  schickte mir unglaubliche Notizen mit
den Ringen, Dinge wie Bitte schmelzen Sie das
runter, es verursachte mir nur Elend, es gab
all diese Briefe, die mir erzählten,
dass sie von Männern in ihren eigenen Kirchen sexuell angegriffen wurden
und dass sie sich fühlten, als
wären sie diese bodengeschädigten Menschen
wegen etwas, das jemand anderes ihnen angetan hat,
ich meine, sie haben
diese Briefe zerrissen, und ja, es gab
eine Menge Kritik, die Leute verloren den
Verstand, die konservativen Christen hassten
das,
sie dachten, es sei Götzendienst, aber sie
machten sie golden und quasi ja richtig
Also, aber ich bin nicht gestört, weil meine Arbeit
nicht für sie ist, ja, es ist für diese Frauen.
Issei, der SAB, grüßt in seinem ersten Jahr
als Ligamann, Land, über Gedankenteams
, ein paar Diesel oder als Serviceteller,
Mann, Khannas Respekt, Ian, für die
Gewürze  oder die jungfräuliche Schwester von Fresh Tina,
die vielleicht unter Stigmatisierung steht, aber ich denke
, das ist ein Risiko, das ich bereit bin einzugehen, ja,
wenn es zwei Menschen Freiheit bietet, die
sich wie in Bindung fühlen  Wenn sich ihre
Entführer verspottet fühlen, stört mich das nicht.
Ich mache mir mehr Sorgen
um die Freiheit, die es bietet, wenn die meisten
Mehrheiten der BVA sogar jetzt nach
dem Mittagessen in Takunda nach dem Abstiegsessen
danach gehen, wie im Drehbuch
die Mütter im Schisma geworden sind,
fühlen sich Essig und Silicon Valley abgelenkt.
Ich habe einen CCNE-Sofa-Biss, das ist
dieser Tim-Krankheiten, die so in einem Reifen
stecken  Amerika scheint
auch weniger säkular zu sein als
unsere Hosen, und Sie haben auch diese
Geschichte der Staatskirche, die den Amerikanern
sehr fremd ist. Ich fühle mich nie
amerikanischer, als wenn ich an einem Ort bin
, der eine Staatskirche hat, und ich sehe  Wie
verbunden sind die beiden Dinge, die sich bewusst sind, dass
Alice privat quasi ein Mensch mit MIT
verbracht hat und Garrett und der gelegentliche
Finanzier ja ja genau und so ist
es einfach, es ist persönlicher, es ist weniger
Civ  ic ja
, aber ich habe festgestellt, dass es
hier in Europa Leute gibt, die meine Bücher lesen
und die auch von der Botschaft überzeugt zu sein scheinen,
also ich meine, als ich in
meiner Gemeinde war, sagten die Leute in gewisser Weise, dass sie es liebten,
dass ich das war  Sie hatten eine Predigerin
, die sich selbst klar predigte und
sie es einfach mithören ließ, ja, und
es gibt eine Art, wie ich diese Dinge schreibe,
weil sie es sind, was ich
hören muss, es ist ein Prozess, den ich
durchmachen muss, mhm und dann  wenn es
für andere hilfreich ist freut mich
das und wenn andere
negativ darauf reagieren hat es nichts
mit mir zu tun es hat mit ihnen zu tun also
hat das CMT ein kleines kommando ist es ja unser
haus aller sünder und heiligen  Augen
ja, Arzt als überflüssig Bedingung,
es gibt einen Weg, auf dem das wahr ist, und ich habe
es aus dem geschaffen, was ich
in der Welt, in der es war, existieren wollte
, aber um der Führer dieser Kirche in dieser
Situation zu sein, musste es für sie sein, wenn es so war
war wirklich nur für mich ich wäre noch
da  e Ich bin im Juli gegangen, weil ich nicht
wollte, dass es ein Gründersyndrom hat, also habe ich vor
zehn Jahren angefangen, meine Abreise im ersten Jahr der Kirche zu
planen, mich wieder zu beschimpfen, und dann weiß ich richtig,
ja, gut, und ruf mir einen Flug, den
du nicht siehst  passieren süße Leine das ist
schamlos Sriman besaß die Farm G in einer
genauen Schwelle
bestätigen eine Co-Lehrerin Ich habe nicht den Stock
eine beschissene Sexualität zu kontrollieren Ära besessen
siehe Anika
daher sogar völlig unberührt le die
fränkischen Missionen mephone Education
Agency würden wir finden  Zustimmung
gut, dass alles zustande kam, weil
ich in der lutherischen Kirche der
Angelica Lutheran Church in Amerika ordiniert bin,
was in Amerika eine ziemlich
liberale Konfession ist, ja, aber ich musste
etwas unterschreiben, als ich ordiniert wurde, das
besagte, dass ich treu sein würde  in der Ehe oder
zölibatär als Single, ja, worüber ich
nicht viel nachgedacht habe, ich schäme mich zu
sagen, weil ich verheiratet war und es keine
Rolle spielte,
ja, aber dann wurde ich geschieden und ich
erlebte einen tiefgreifenden Unterschied, der ich war
verheiratet mit einem sehr guten Mann aus Venetien,
ja, auch einem lutherischen Pastor, das
stimmt, und aber wir haben uns nie so
verbunden, wie es einer von uns brauchte, also war
es eine sehr einsame Ehe und ohne
jede Art von Intimität, und das war schwer
für mich und  Als ich mich dann scheiden ließ und
anfing, mich mit meinem Freund zu verabreden, und wir uns
auf alle möglichen Arten emotional,
körperlich, sexuell und spirituell verbanden,
war es erstaunlich für mich, als wäre es gut für
meinen Geist, meinen Körper, mein Herz und meinen
Geist, und doch war ich es jetzt  Ich missachtete eine
Regel, die mir die Kirche gegeben hatte,
und ich war gesünder, und so fand ich es einfach
verwirrend, wie warum sollte die Kirche,
warum es besser für meine Gemeinde ist,
wenn ich keinen Sex habe, machte ich einfach keinen
Sinn, weil ich  Ich fühlte mich wie
eine offenherzigere, sanftere Person, als ein
deutlicher Neid auf einige, weil ich
Spiritist vs. bin und Alkane X gut
als Gründe und als Haut betrachten kann
war alles im Gange und ich
war ein paar Wochen mit Eric zusammen und dann
musste ich sehen, ob ich meinen Freund finde, ja,
also musste ich die UK-Ausgabe
in der deutschen Ausgabe meines letzten Buches unterstützen, damit
ich auf Tour war  dreieinhalb Wochen
und nachdem wir nur ein paar Wochen zusammen waren,
ging mir das alles durch den Kopf, und ich dachte, er ist kein Christ, und
ich habe mit ihm gesprochen, und ich sagte, warum, glauben Sie
, hat die Kirche versucht,
Sex so lange und ohne zu kontrollieren  einen Schlag überspringend,
sagte er, ich habe immer angenommen, dass die
Kirche Sex als ihre Konkurrenz betrachtet, und ich
dachte, oh, ich schreibe ein Buch, ich
sollte ein anderes
schreiben, ich werde schreiben, und ich war es, das
herauszufinden, wie ja, ich  wusste, dass es wahr ist, aber ich
musste in anderthalb bis
zwei Jahren des Schreibens herausfinden, wie es wahr war,
ja, und so habe ich meine
Gemeindemitglieder fast zwei Jahre lang interviewt und
nur gesagt, welche Botschaft Sie
von der Kirche erhalten haben, welche Kirche Sie auch sind
aufgewachsen in über Sex im Körper und
Geschlecht und  Wie hat sich diese Nachricht auf
Sie ausgewirkt und wie haben Sie Ihr Erwachsenenleben navigiert,
und dieses Buch ist das
Ergebnis dieser Gespräche, die
Devadas über das Stadtkommando bei
RCC so intim machen kann, aber die Szenen der
Intimität, oh Gott, das ja,
zuallererst II  war schockiert, wie viele Leute
sofort bereit waren, dieses
Gespräch mit mir zu führen, mhm
, als würden sie fast darauf warten, gefragt zu werden,
und aber dann hatte ich das Gefühl, dass sie
einfach herausströmten, dass sie in der Lage waren,
diese Verbindung zwischen der Botschaft, die die
Kirche ihnen gab, und vielem herzustellen  des Schadens, den
sie erlitten hatten, und so ist die Prämisse
des Buches, dass wir, wenn die Lehren der
Kirche Menschen schaden
, die Lehren überdenken sollten, damit
wir einer Idee oder Doktrin
oder einer Interpretation eines Bibelvers niemals treuer sein sollten
als wir  sind für Menschen so das ist der Fall
Ich mache in dem Buch oben Assistenten
auftreten ziemlich Geschlecht Sexualität zu sehen
Fonda Keisha wie ich sah ja weil ich sah
Norma kann nicht ruinieren verschmutzt gut denke ich a
Vieles davon hat mit der Angst vor Frauen zu tun.
Tatsächlich denke ich, dass Frauenfeindlichkeit die
Wurzel vieler sexueller Lehren in der
Kirche ist, von
denen ich denke, dass Frauen in
gewisser Weise als eine Art Bedrohung männlicher
Macht wahrgenommen werden  Männer können
ihre Dominanz in der Gesellschaft irgendwie aufrechterhalten,
indem sie die Körper und
die Sexualität von Frauen kontrollieren. Das
ist nur die menschliche Geschichte, die nicht der
Meinung entspricht. Ich denke, wir sehen es irgendwie in der
menschlichen Geschichte, aber ein anderer Grund ist,
weil es etwas Transzendentes gibt
Die menschliche Sexualität ist geheimnisvoll
, und ich denke, dass sie es sowohl
mit Sex als auch mit Religion zulässt.
Ich denke, wir suchen nach einer
Art Linderung unserer existentiellen
Einsamkeit, der Tatsache, dass diese Angst, die
wir als Menschen erleben,
verwurzelt ist  in der Tatsache, dass wir auf einer
existentiellen Ebene allein waren, und so
suchen wir die Vereinigung in der Religion, wir suchen die Vereinigung
mit Gott und den Insekten, wir sehen die Vereinigung mit einer
anderen Person, und beides
hilft, dies zu lindern  existenzielle
Einsamkeit, also denke ich, das ist eines der
Dinge, die es gemeinsam hat,
seit ein Bananen-Fundamentalist Evangelischer
Alocasia in Indonesien von Coxon Hamdi
Stefan Distanz, es passiert, Okazaki, sie
hatte keinen Jesus, einen Virus Wiggly, also oh, ich
habe Jesus nie gehasst, nur um das klarzustellen
war das einzige, was ich behalten hatte, das
mir noch gehörte, das war ein schicker Essig, Hostas-
Akazie, der Legalismus, also bin ich
in einer Kirche aufgewachsen, in der Frauen buchstäblich
nicht einmal laut vor Männern beten konnten,
in gewisser Weise  Ja, ich meine, ich habe noch
nie eine Frau in irgendeiner Art von
spiritueller oder religiöser Führung in einer
Kirche bis alle 927
gesehen  Pastor oder
pastorale Stimme für viele
Menschen zu sein, die sehr
konservativ christlich aufgewachsen sind und
dennoch Teile davon haben wollen, die sie
halten können und doch
vieles davon aus li-Gründen ablehnen müssen  ke
Selbsterhaltung ja
mr.  Chaffetz, nein, es ist Kanawa, wütend auf
die Kommunen, die Fernseher einlösen wollen. Sie haben
jemals Vater Hank geholfen, in 20
Minuten zu vermeiden
Vakuum-Whisker Wenig Gott
hält das für in Ja, es war so
oft, dass ich die einzige religiöse Person
und meine Gruppe von Freunden war, und das war
damals der Fall, ich war noch nicht zum Seminar gegangen,
aber ich war in Genesung und ich
hatte  Im Stand-up war
ich Stand-up-Comedy und so erlag ein Freund von
mir, der auch Stand-up-Comic war
und bei meinem 12-Schritte-Meeting war
, seinem Kampf gegen eine
Geisteskrankheit und starb  durch Selbstmord und wir hatten
seine Beerdigung fand in einem Comedy-Club in der
Innenstadt von Denver im Comedy Works statt
und es war voll und meine Freunde
sahen mich nur an und sie sagten, du
könntest die Beerdigung richtig machen, du könntest
die Predigt halten und ich '  Ich denke schon, aber
es war nur, weil ich der einzige war
fromme person hat er ein okapi
hat draußen nicht gehänselt war er so quasi
necken schlank schritt seidenstoff war er
gefühl ja das war als ich zurück in
die kirche gekommen war du weißt ich war das war als
ich zum christentum zurückgekehrt war  An diesem
Punkt war ich seit ein paar Jahren
wieder dabei, und so schaute ich auf
die Menge, als ich seine Laudatio hielt,
und es waren alles Comics und Queers und
genesende Alkoholiker und Akademiker, und
ich dachte, oh, tun sie es nicht  Ich habe
keinen Pastor und dann war mein nächster Gedanke, oh
nein, ich glaube, ich sollte der
Pastor sein, es war nur dieses Wurzel-Bingo, ja,
und so war
es dieses Gefühl der Berufung, also hatte ich
nie das Gefühl, dass ich der
Kirche angehören wollte  Pastor Ich wollte der
Pastor meines Volkes sein, ja, ja, ich habe es noch nicht
einmal getan. Ezekiel Cocoon, der
Cabochon, der genau das Haus aller Sünder und
Heiligen ist, den Mundy sogar in der ganzen Vergangenheit
gab, waren Oscar-Läden und Viacom-
Städte und Anrufe und Staatsbürgerkunde, er ist heiß und
cool  Ja, es ist nicht so
schnell gewachsen, wie ich wollte  Die ersten paar Jahre war
es sehr frustrierend, aber schließlich wurde
ich gebeten, bei diesem stadtweiten Ostergottesdienst zu predigen,
der in Red
Rocks ist, einem sehr berühmten natürlichen
Amphitheater außerhalb von Denver, und
es gibt 10.000 Menschen, und ich hatte diese
kleine Kirche mit ungefähr 40 Menschen  und dann brachte
die Zeitung in meiner Stadt, die Denver Post,
diese Titelgeschichte über mich am
Osterwochenende und darüber, warum diese
Frau die Predigerin in Red Rocks ist, und dann hat sich
meine Gemeinde
deswegen über Nacht verdoppelt, so viel
davon  Dass die Leute von außen
begannen, es zu bemerken und mehr Leute davon
hörten, ist einer der Gründe, warum es wuchs,
denke ich, Mr.  Osamu tasaka
erlaubte Liegeplätze FIBA diese Hilfe Claud
a Englisch hmm warum ich den Glauben habe ich t
e hmm gut m
in Freund Frank Schaefer der S
hn seines Francis Schaeffer, der ein berü
mter Engel ist, er hatte eine schwierige Art der Erzie
ung mit der Kirche und doch ist er immer noch
hrist und  In einem Interview
sagte er einmal etwas, das mich immer dazu bringen wird
, ihn zu hassen, weil ich wünschte, ich hätte es gesagt,
was jemand gesagt hat, aber du bist immer noch
Teil davon, du bist immer noch Teil des
Christentums, richtig, und er sagt, ich bin und
dann er  Alles, was ich sagen kann, ist Folgendes: Wenn
ich mehr als alles andere auf der
Welt ein Atheist sein wollte,
wüsste ich nur, zu
Gott zu beten, dass er mich zu einem macht, und so fühle ich mich, als könnte
ich das nicht  Helfen Sie mir, ich als eine
andere Freundin von mir, die Rachel hielt. Evans
sagt, dies ist die Geschichte von Jesus, bei
der ich das Risiko eingehen werde, mich zu irren,
als wäre es eine so fesselnde Geschichte
für mich, dass sie mich nicht in
Ruhe lässt  bedeutet für mich neue und andere und
schöne Dinge und es ist a  Linse,
durch die ich mich selbst und andere Menschen
auf der Welt sehe, und ich kann ihm einfach nicht entkommen,
selbst wenn ich wollte, mm gun sagte, sich
hinzusetzen, denn das sollen sie sein,
ja, danke,
es hat Spaß gemacht, danke
[Musik],
du
[Musik  ]